voici les premières images du futur
bâtiment de l'usiné de traitement des
eaux usées du siaap à achères une
reconstruction suite à l' incendie du 3
juillet 2019
une nouvelle organisation autour de deux
bâtiments avec un site réservé au
stockage de chlorure ferrique à
l'intérieur du bâtiment de la classe
population ce qui a surtout brûlé c'est
le stockage de chlorure ferrique donc ce
stockage là on va le reconstruire à côté
et du coup avec des mesures en termes de
sécurité incendie qui sont beaucoup plus
draconiennes que celles dont on
disposait dans l'ancien bâtiment
depuis un an le bâtiment touché par
l'incendié a été nettoyé les travaux de
reconstruction devraient être lancés en
2021 pour une livraison en 2022
en attendant le siaap travaille sur une
nouvelle organisation
objectif renforcer la sécurité
aujourd'hui on est encore dans une
culture où c'est la production donc le
traitement des eaux qui est la priorité
est la sécurité n'est pas encore une
priorité suffisamment importante pour
l'ensemble de nos agents et notamment
pour nos encadrants donc c'est ce
travail là qu'on va mener dans les deux
trois ans qui viennent
les résultats d'un audit et d'une
expertise sur l'origine de cet incendie
ont été présentés lors d'une réunion
d'information auprès des parties
prenantes à la sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
la cause la plus probable du départ de
feu serait un défaut d'isolement de
câbles électriques
l'incendié étant d'origine électrique il
est susceptible de se reproduire et
qu'il faut donc d'une part diminuer ce
risque et surtout en limiter les
conséquences pour rassurer les élus
locaux et la population les services de
l'état poursuivent la communication sur
ce dossier
des exercices de sécurité devrait être
organisé en novembre au niveau des
opérations de commandement puis avec les
maires et la population en avril 2021